oyu gaz
n'ont pas d'eau je sais que vous êtes
tous en vacances au soleil a profité
retirez vos lunettes de soleil asseyez
venus profiter en passer un petit moment
sympa convivial vous les remettraient
après n'a voté vidéo c'est le nom du
seul bris dit d'aujourd'hui ça fait un
moment qu'on n'a pas fait anti sobre
éditant vrai parce qu'il ya pas mal de
vidéos réactions que je fais ou c'est
pas des sabres est dit c'est juste on
pioche à droite à gauche des trucs sur
le web et j'ai réagi mais c'est pas des
trucs qui viennent d'inde un seul et
même ce bris dit celui-là fait ya un peu
plus d'un an maintenant c'est un clasico
le titre on peut le traduire en ne me
donnait pas les probabilités c'est que
des postes on se dit mais non commencés
possible c'est parti et on commence tout
de suite avec regardez moi ce couple
tellement mignon telle moqueries août
lui l'habitat et ding dong elle elle
habite à paris et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé le jour de l'anniversaire de leur
couple ils ont chacun voulu faire une
surprise à l'autre en allant dans sa
ville sauf qu'ils sont tellement cute
qu'ils ont fait en même temps et du coup
lui s'est retrouvé solo à paris et elle
s'est retrouvée seule widing bourgault
non c'est trop cube pouvait pas mettre
d'accord offert des surprises mignoni ou
de mieux que les autres coûts
funchal où de la romance ça les gars
j'ai jamais su ce était fake ou pas ce
truc en 1990 le pare brise d'un avion de
british airways s'est barré en plein vol
et le capitaine de bord c'est retrouver
aspiré par le pare brise et il ya des
gens de l'équipage qui lui ont tenu les
jambes pendant à peu près 20 minutes
avec lui qui avait du coup son corps à
l'extérieur de l'avion quoi j'ai lu
plusieurs news comme ça parce que je
crois que c'est pas un cas isolé je
crois que c'est arrivé plusieurs fois
mais j'ai jamais réussi à savoir à quel
point cet effet que l'image du bas est
clairement fake mais est-ce que
l'histoire les
snipers d'insectes avec une sarbacane
[Musique]
arrêtez d'abandonner vos enfants à leur
naissance dans des tribus ça me donne
envie de faire une serbe à cannes avec
un effaceur là ça fait longtemps gelé
pas fait cette fois ce ne sont pas des
balles une flèche a endommagé un câble
électrique de cinq journées ce bourreau
arrêté d'abandonner vos enfants dans des
tribus qu'est ce que c'est que cette
ville on en parle à chaque fois mais
vraiment arrêter de faire genre quand il
se passe un truc de fou que c'est normal
flex et un bon coup foot et nous sommes
attraper son propre bouquet elle envoie
son briquet
et rebondit dans un rideau
normalement quand tu attrapes le bouquet
ça veut dire que tu es la prochaine note
marié j'ai donc bien l'impression que tu
seras surtout la prochaine à niveau
c'est un train à pleine vitesse avec des
gens assis sur le toit mais qui ça peut
bien n'être jamais série or c'est tom
krause
ça m'est arrivé de le croiser il était
assis sur l'ale de mon avion la dernière
fois sacré tom cruise la
sorcellerie au flipper
le rêve je pense je pensais même pas que
c'était possible elle est dans la
position parfaite c'est infini oh là là
que moi je suis jaloux apparemment la
foudre a frappé un feu d'artifice
incroyable donc déjà tu as la chance de
voir un feu d'artifice - cette année je
n'ai pas vu d'accord et tu vois la
foudre fera but veut un petit fils j'en
ai marre quand est ce qui m'arrive a un
truc improbable un véritable héros a
sauvé ce gars d'une amende de 300
dollars vous voyez ces miettes que vous
mettez par terre quand vous mangez votre
bailleur sandwich sur un banc cet amour
elle nous le rende roulent moins
vite toi sale chien va y aura pâture une
boîte pour te sauver oh ça va être un
très beau tir bas pourquoi ils trouvent
ça ouf il s'est passé quoi c'est une
reprise de volée un peu moyenne non je
suis ça jugé trop dénigrer à ses
intérêts dans la voiture aux excuses moi
bout de chou j'ai été mauvaises langues
avaient pas viser les cages nul
t'éclater aucune carrière les quatre
pour toi une vidéo
qui va faire chavirer notre coeur avec
la no way
[Musique]
pourquoi si satisfaisant et regardez ce
qu'ils est à l'heure même les animaux qu
ils savent qu'ils ont fait un truc de
fou hyflex up flex voilà mon chat a
disparu pendant deux jours du coup j'ai
mis une annonce sur facebook je les
retrouvais cinq minutes après 30 minutes
après mon voisin a déposé un chat chez
moi en pensant que c'était le mien
maintenant j'ai deux chats qui sont les
mêmes tous voisins il y avait pas envie
d'abandonner son chat par hasard au y
correspond at on annonce tient durant
ton chat mais pas du tout c'est pas la
même couleur a bientôt prends soin de
ton chat c'est pas du tout - ou bisous
j'allais prendre une photo d'un arc en
ciel et la foudre a frappé au même
moment waouh un jouet un ressort sur le
tableau de bord j'adore quand je vois ça
dans une voiture je trouve sahara est
trop cool la foudre est tout à coup
super george lucas ce qui apparaît dans
un documentaire random ça j'adore cybard
hantise les gars
oh c'est tellement drôle ça c'est arrivé
à beaucoup plus de gens qu'on ne le
pense mais il le cache évidemment parce
qu'ils apparaissent dans un truc c'est
un peu la honte et tout s'est pas
exactement même chose mais dans le même
genre seb il ya très longtemps il avait
fait une vidéo dans un manège aux
tuileries et depuis ce même manège aux
tuileries affiche en boucle des extraits
de la vidéo deux scènes en question sur
des écrans géants devant le manège et ça
me fait trop rire que huit ans après ce
soit encore là et il ya encore des gens
qui a sa fête foraine et qu'ils fassent
des stéroïdes mentionne c'est bon je
trouve ça archi drôle ma grand mère est
morte le jour de l'anniversaire de mon
grand père mon grand père est mort le
jour de l'anniversaire de ma grand mère
c'est beau et il arrivait à se faire des
surprises entre paris et de mon goût il
n'arrivait pas
l'image du finish incroyable
qu'est ce que j'aime les jeux vidéo pour
ça red dead redemption de dans le genre
il a la palme d'or pour moi c'était un
générateur de situation mais colossal
j'ai hâte du 3
ou attention le baseball au japon c'est
un sacré sport l'un des sports c'est le
sport national
il a attiré tellement fort qu'il va
péter le toit
[Musique]
tweet à radio j si vous allez au japon
un jour aller un batîment center je vous
jure ça vaut grave le coup en plus c'est
pas forcément méga durée la balle et
bien pas forcément hyper vite tu choisis
la vitesse en fait voilà petit monde
tripadvisor pour les squeeze hausse
qu'en donne car causé battu lors de la
seconde guerre mondiale il a été blessé
à l'oeil droit et il en a perdu lèvres
64 ans plus tard il travaillait dans une
grange lorsqu'un cheval lui a mis un
coup de tête sur ce fameux oeil et
soudainement il a retrouvé la vue
moral s'il ya un blème physique fera
plus doux plus fort en place et guéri
quelle est l'explication scientifique
comment il a pu perdre la vue à cause
d'un éclat de trucs et l'a retrouvé
suite un choc c'est fou attendez
attendez quoi c'est une femme qui
malheureusement a vu sa maison est
détruite par un cyclone aux états unis
et en pleine interview à la télé et
retrouve son chien dans les décombres
qu'est vivant qui va bien et tout le
bonheur pour elle comme elle a dû être
contente en plus elle est trop mignonne
1 on retrouve le combo personnes âgées
chien fait pleurer perdent c'est
horrible ce que je vais dire mais je
suis sûr qu'il y en a plein qui vivent
ça quand je pars de chez moi souvent je
pense à hamamatsu et à jumbo je me dis
simon a party prend feu parce
qu'il ya un plein d'électricité ou je
sais pas quelle connerie bon bah là par
bru voilà j'ai pu d'appart c'est la vie
mais par contre mes animaux
comprendront ce qui se passe ils verront
la mort arriver personne sera là pour
les aider c'est horrible et défauts
aussi je me dis ah j'ai soif de boire de
l'eau cette mouche vient de s'envoler et
de s'empaler dans une plante
je trouve ça presque beau elle sait
qu'elle a déconné la sniffer trop
d'excréments elle a voulu en fils
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je sais pas
ou pas ça m'a fait rire comme ça ok les
gars apparemment celle ci est folle
c'est un contrôle de police et le shérif
est clairement un sorcier on y est
comment alors venez au maire
l'image
auteurs mauvaise mon gars moi j'y crois
pas complice clairement il est fou
amoureux de cette femme et il voulait
faire le mec genre je dis un truc et
c'est exactement ce qui se passe à
chérif pour rien allez rentrer ensemble
ce gars est devenu instantanément
millionnaire conte une météorite d'une
valeur de 1,4 million d'euros s'est
crashé dans sa chambre tout son cursus
scolaire un peu chier à ce calcul est
enfin avec passi calculer les gars il
s'est confessée plus tard il a dit qu'il
l'a vendu pour quatorze mille dollars
parce qu'ils savaient pas que l en
valais 1,8 million
au l'ascenseur émotionnel il est dur au
cd mais comparé à pons qui sont rentrés
[Musique]
mes mecs je serais mort d'une crise
cardiaque j'aurais rien pu faire
on avait fait un live on parlera contre
les gars live tweet am extrême annonce
là
dan carpenter a eu la ride de sa vie
quand sa chaise roulante électrique
s'est retrouvé coincé dans la grille
d'une semi remorque et qui s'est fait
pousser sur l'autoroute sur plusieurs
kilomètres à 80 km
battant l'américaine morty on est où là
mais la chaise est incroyable n'ai pas
du tout fait pour aller une telle
vitesse elle a résisté il a eu aucune
blessure
c'est méchant de rire ah ça pour de vrai
c'est bien mais pas non plus il m a
ralenti les gars c'est pas bien
c'est la fin de cette vidéo vous pouvez
remettre vos lunettes de soleil
désormais il est vrai je vais les mettre
aussi j'espère que ça vous a plu ce riz
dit c'est vraiment une valeur sûre façon
tous les trucs de prob à moi ça ma thuôt
fait marrer de ou froid quand il se
passe un truc qui avaient une faible
probable face de ça j'adore on a dit
qu'on allait parler vacances à la fin de
chaque vidéo j'espère qu'elle se passe
très bien pour vous je peux pas finir
une vidéo sans vous d'art oned un peu la
crème solaire bas alors on l'a mais
c'est le zénith en plus cela a déjà
d'être traîné je vous laisse tranquille
a très vite les secours
[Musique]
e